[Music]
war is getting sneakier Wars going
underground and we have to go
underground with it we have to fight in
the shadows otherwise we will be left
behind so for example you know in this
type of new environment
some of the best weapons do not fire
bullets in the old day is the old rules
of war when the Soviet Union wanted to
arrest the West wanted to sort of freak
out NATO what it would do was hold a
huge military exercise and the border of
Germany East and West Germany 150,000
troops and NATO and the United States
wasn't sure like well is this exercise
or could it be a real invasion and that
would shake things up but that's the old
days the innocent days today when Russia
wants to shake up Europe what they do is
they weaponize refugees they
deliberately bombed civilian centers in
the Syria
creig an avalanche of refugees into
Europe which creates breaks it which
creates the rise of right-wing national
parties that want to diss disembowel the
European Union the Soviets wish they can
do that if they can only have done that
so I think this is an example of how
wars the future will be fought they will
not even look like Wars to the
traditional mind and a few heads will
explode in the Pentagon but that's okay
when people think of the threats that
face our country today they think of
Russia China terrorism pandemics etc but
those are not the worst problems the
worst threat is systemic it's growing
entropy in the global system it's
persistent conflict that's something I
call durable disorder adorable disorder
is and what durable disorder means is
that we have an emerging global system
that can contain problems but not solve
them meanwhile we have this you know
post-1945 idea of a liberal war world
order that the US sort of champions
and rules upon but that world has gone
away and we're not prepared for what
follows next for the United States the
last successful war was World War two we
won decisively in 1945 the world ran on
vacuum tubes yet that the idea of
conventional war is still the strategic
paradigm of which the Pentagon the
military the modern national security
establishment is built around and this
is dangerously wrong when you ask people
to think about the future of war often
what they tell you is something that
looks like world war two with better
technology but there is nothing more
unconventional today the conventional
war nobody fights this way
when people think about what warfare is
I think of John Wayne or Saving Private
Ryan they think of killing more enemies
taking more territory and flying your
flag over the enemies capital they think
of Berlin and 45 they think of Japan's
surrender on the battleship the USS
Missouri and then they wonder why
there's not a USS Missouri moment
against the Taliban against Isis the
reason is nobody fights this war this
way of war anymore
yet we are mired in the past and as long
as we're a Marg in the past and you know
more has moved on we'll be left behind
and even an undefeated military can lose
if there's one maxim for the last 70
years of war is that technology is not
decisive and warfare if you look at you
know big powerful technologically
advanced militaries go up against low
level you know Luddites who confound
them you know whether it's the you know
Mujahideen in Afghanistan against the
Soviets or America fighting in Vietnam
against the North Vietnamese etc Iraq
Afghanistan this is this is the one
without question the one thing we should
all agree on yet for some reason people
think we need to double down and invest
in technology for warfare
in fact for most people they can't even
imagine the future of war without high
tech it's such is the bias that we have
for it but this is the definition of
insanity doing the same thing again and
again expecting a different result for
example take the f-35 fighter jet now we
have not fought we've not had a
strategic dogfight since the Korean War
so why do we need more fighter jets I do
not know we already have the best
fighter jets and the f-16 the F you know
you know 15 and the f-18 so why do we
need the f-35 and what's even more
amazing is that we have spent more on
this small airplane we've spent then any
other weapon in history we've spent 1.5
trillion dollars on the f-35 that's more
than Russia's GDP if the f-35 were a
country its GDP would be in the top 15
of the world and amazingly is flown zero
combat missions in two long wars and
we're buying more of them right so the
idea of putting our faith in technology
is ludicrous it is absolute Icarus a lot
of people think that the future will
belong to a AI artificial intelligence
and cyber and cyber war but the truth is
if you ask 11 people 10 well 10 or 12
experts on what cyber war is you'll get
20 different answers all the cyber
people can agree on it's ones and zeroes
in space you know they always come up
with these fantastical things oh the
power grid for the East Coast can come
down you know and Hollywood depicts this
and James Bond movies but in reality
cyber all cyber does it allows us to do
old things and new ways old things like
espionage theft propaganda and sabotage
something new about it I mean it's not a
new way of war it just allows us to do
old things in new ways so technology is
not the Savior that most
futurists pretend it is when it comes to
warfare
[Music]